auf der Messe ist es spürbar der
europäische Automarkt ist unter Druck
chinesische e-Autos sind auf dem
Vormarsch gerade bei den kleineren
Modellen doch auch die sind immer noch
recht teuer
35.000 Euro für einen e Kompaktwagen
immerhin die Batterien werden besser 700
km Reichweite mit einer Ladung sind
inzwischen machbar es wird auch eine
Woche des Protests E-Autos statt
Verbrenner reicht den Aktivisten nicht
sie fordern ein grundsätzliches Umdenken
beim Verkehr die E-Autos konzeptionell
sind dazu da dass die Menschen weniger
an Luftverschmutzung sterben die machen
nichts oder sehr wenig wenn es um
Klimaschutz geht oder Energieaufwand für
dieses Auto bleibt einfach bestehen und
das ist etwas was wir uns nicht leisten
können was sich der Planet nicht leisten
kann immerhin die Messe versucht den
Blick zu weiten Mobilität mit allen
Spielarten die neuesten E-Bikes aber
auch der Sprung ins metterwars wo man
bei einer tuellen Probefahrt z.B mal den
Bremsassistenten ausreizen kann
ja und bei mir ist jetzt der CEO von
Opel Florian Hüttel guten Morgen wir
haben es den Beitrag ja gerade schon
gehört die Kritik auch von den
Aktivisten ist ja sehr groß dass sei
alles Greenwashing das sei keine echte
grüne Wände was sagen sie denn zu denen
ja schönen guten Morgen Frau sah wissen
sie es besteht kein Zweifel der
Klimaschutz ist die größte Aufgabe
unserer Generation
gleichzeitig halten wir auch
individuelle Mobilität für ein hohes
Gutes zu schützen und zu entwickeln Geld
und wir bei Opel haben uns diesen beiden
Zielen konsequent verschrieben wir
entwickeln seit einigen Jahren
konsequent die Marke unsere Unternehmen
hin zur Elektromobilität wir bieten
heute schon ein breites Angebot an rein
elektrischen Fahrzeugen an einem
emissionsfreien Fahrzeugen die sich
stetig steigender Popularität ja
erfreuen und wir zeigen hier auf der
Messe auch weitere Neuheiten mit dem
Corsa Elektrik den wir hier sehen mit
dem Astra Sports Tour Elektrik und wir
werden bei diesen Weg auch in Zukunft
konsequent weitergehen bis hin zum Rhein
elektrischen Hersteller wenigen Jahren
jetzt wenn man sich auf der Messe
umschaut dann merkt man schon dass eine
gewisse ja chinesische Wucht da auf die
europäischen Hersteller zukommt viele
Firmen viele Marken viele jetzt wird es
gerade laut ich hoffe sie hören es nicht
allzu schlimm im Hintergrund also eine
große Konkurrenz wie stellen Sie sich da
auf denn es geht ja auch um die
Batterietechnik die fest in chinesischer
Hand ist um Ressourcen wie kommt man
dagegen an ja die Transformation der
Autoindustrie hin zu
reine elektromobilität ist eine sehr
grundlegende Transformation die lässt
sehr viel Platz für Innovationen auch
Platz für neue Konkurrenz und ja damit
haben wir uns im Moment zu tun Ihre
Frage nach der Batterietechnik ist
wichtig in der Batterietechnik liegt
heute noch ein großer Kostenanteil in
einem Elektroauto die er nach wie vor
relativ hochpreisig sind und wir
arbeiten da intensiv daran auch die
Batterietechnik weiter zu entwickeln hin
zu bezahlbarer Technologie
hinzuhören Laufzeiten hinzu schnelleren
mahlzeiten und das ist ein wichtiger
Teil unserer Entwicklung wir bei Opel um
bei srelantis entwickeln in Zukunft
unsere Batterien selbst wir bauen die
auch in Europa in den gigafactories mit
ACC und sichern uns so auch in Zukunft
den Zugang zu Technologie und die
Weiterentwicklung wann kommt denn ein
wirklich bezahlbares E-Auto denn auch
der Corsa ist ja momentan noch bei knapp
35.000 Euro wann sehen wir denn mal ein
E-Auto für 20.000 also wir machen da
große Fortschritte so ein Corsa den
Corsa electric können Sie heute schon
für 239 € im Monat leasen ohne Anzahlung
und wir kommen da langsam wirklich auch
im Bereich die immer größere
Käuferschicht ansprechen können und ja
die Bezahlbarkeit von Elektroautos ist
sehr wichtigen bearbeiten intensiv daran
dass auch wirklich immer bezahlbar zu
machen also da ist viel Musik drin die
nächsten Jahre werden da hoffentlich
auch noch ein bisschen mehr Spielraum
auch für die kleineren Geldbeutel
bringen schauen wir mal